so perhaps my favorite story over the
weekend was that john roberts chief
justice of the supreme court was
screaming at the other justices saying
that
they have to dismiss the texas versus
pennsylvania case that i covered last
week
this story was obvious nonsense for many
different reasons the first as i covered
in the video
is that the case was absolute nonsense
it didn't fit the court's jurisdiction
the court
effectively voted 9-0 to get rid of it
no one was going to grant cert on this
the second is that the supreme court
simply doesn't leak you never hear from
the insides mainly because the court
clerks care about their reputation and
want to work for really fancy law firms
so
they're not going to leak and the third
is that they couldn't scream in person
because they didn't meet
in person the supreme court has been
meeting in person or even holding oral
arguments in person for months because
of covid but if you want some christmas
cheer check out this video i did on all
the laws broken in national lampoon's
christmas vacation and i'll see you
in court